this is Friday November 4th four days
until the 2016 presidential election
between Secretary Clinton representing
the Democrats and Donald Trump
representing the Russians and this is
the closer as we sit here waiting for
today's newest story about the FBI
improperly immorally and illegally
trying to interfere with next Tuesday's
elections this question when should we
reclassify the form of the government of
the United States from democracy to
fascism I mean do we wait until the
prospective inauguration next January of
a present and who does not seem
interested in our Constitution or if the
FBI is already trying to help one party
seize control of our governments
technically is that good enough to just
cut to the chase and say we are already
living in a goddamned fascist state
should we just admit that next Tuesday
is not an election to try to prevent
fascism and a dictatorship here but one
that is trying to get a woman elected
who will fight back against the National
detectives who have already decided
freedom here is secondary to what they
want and who they like the latest FBI
nightmare broke last night although a
newer one might have broken since you
started watching this so you should
check reuters reported that the bureau
is so out of control that its hapless
director james comey shouted fire in a
crowded theater a week ago today for
fear that if he did not somebody else in
his Clown College would by means of
leaking The News Service also reported
quote to enforcement sources familiar
with the FBI's New York field office
which initially discovered the emails
said a faction of investigators based in
the office is known to be hostile to
Hillary Clinton to me that's grounds to
you know close the FBI's New York field
office fire everybody in it bring in
some placeholder agents from elsewhere
to investigate actual you know crimes
while a special prosecutor investigates
how many of the fired New York field
office employees have violated the Hatch
Act by acting politically during an
election season and I mean if they're
acting politically for Trump or for
Clinton the moment a nationwide policing
operation is corrupted by politics right
left or middle its goddamned fascism but
of course all the other nightmares from
the FBI suggest they're not acting left
or middle yesterday the estimable Wayne
Barrett of The Daily Beast underscored a
timeline that nearly all of us had
missed as Barrett noted last Wednesday
god damned Rudy Guiliani
who has faced it gone crazy told Fox
News that his boy Trump had quote got a
surprise or two that you're gonna hear
about in the next few days I mean I'm
talking about some pretty big surprises
we've got a couple of things up our
sleeve that should turn this thing
around
two days later commis statement
coincidence no doubt reporter Barrett
also noted that Giuliani and his friend
the former New York FBI chief James Cole
strim had both boasted though being in
contact with active FBI agents about
Secretary Clinton active agents are not
supposed to be talking to a man employed
as a surrogate by a political campaign
active agents are not supposed to be
talking to anybody outside the agency
about a presidential candidate active
agents are certainly not supposed to be
talking to a man like Kallstrom who runs
a charity that took more than a million
dollars from trump's hissy-fit charity
telethon during the Iowa Republican
primary it's against the goddamned law
although why should they worry about the
law they're the goddamned FBI agents and
they think they should run this country
without annoying interference from you
or me or the goddamned laws some of them
also appear to be idiots Tuesday the New
York Times revealed that in August the
bureau had descended to the stage of to
borrow Generalissimo Trump's phrase all
I know is what's on the Internet
the FBI's poking around the Clinton
Foundation which found nothing quote was
based mostly on information that had
surfaced in news stories and the book
Clinton cash according to several law
enforcement officials briefed on the
case Clinton cash Clinton cash the book
written by Peter Schweitzer an editor of
the right wing nut job
goddamned fascist website brag parts or
Clinton cash the movie produced by
Steven van
then chairman of the right-wing nut job
goddamned fascist website Breitbart
before he took a cut in prestige to run
Trump's goddamn campaign facing an
investigation on Clinton cash
what because there weren't any comic
books available on the subject this is
not just fascism this is idiot fascism
and that is the one shining hope on the
ever darkening horizon yes
Trump admires dictators and he was
saddened that arrested terror suspects
get food or medical care and he calls
protests by abused minority groups race
riots and he wants to automatically
deport any undocumented American merely
accused of a crime and he wants national
stop-and-frisk and racial profiling and
a religious test for people entering the
country and he wants to curb the First
Amendment but he is also stupid stupid
stupid enough to still say in
Jacksonville yesterday quote I'm also
honored to have the greatest temperament
that anybody has as if he won an award
for it as if there had been a worldwide
ranking of all 7 billion people well
hell maybe one of the voices in Trump's
head actually told him he had received
an award for it and all we should be
hoping for is that one of the other
voices in Trump's head should now tell
him he has no effing clue what the word
temperament means and while I will not
walk back by an inch my contention that
the best historical match to the
campaign this Macy's Thanksgiving Day
Parade balloon in a suit is running he's
the one that Adolf Hitler ran in 1932
and 1933
I'll also continue to insist the Trump
is still far dumber than he looks
and he looks radiantly dumb it was
neither ironing or subtle strategy that
made Trump sent his spectacularly dense
wife onto the campaign trail yesterday
where she found that as first lady she
would advocate against the parts of
social media that are too mean and too
tough and filled with insults based on
looks and intelligence and 318
million Americans simultaneously
wondered if this woman had ever met her
own husband or whether she was capable
of understanding that if abusing
people's looks and intelligence on
Twitter were a crime her husband would
be serving the first of a hundred and
forty seven consecutive life sentences
so yes we already live in a goddamn
fascist state with the FBI trying to
choose the next president and the would
be first lady coming out and advocating
some kind of first amendment altering
monitoring of your social media and that
should make you goddamned angry
to paraphrase one of the great speeches
of all time all I know is that first
you've got to get mad you've got to say
I'm an American citizen goddamn it my
democracy has value but when you get mad
this weekend get mad with gusto and
vigor and confidence instead of
depression or anxiety or panic these
people Trump Giuliani Bannen Comey the
FBI that madame tussauds version of a
would-be first lady
these people are fascists fearful
fascists but they are also morons and we
can beat morons
we can beat morons with the weapons
still left to us the ballot the ballot
and your efforts to convince just one
other person you know to vote in defense
of their birthright and in defense of
democracy and against morons against
goddamn fascist morons
that's the closer I'm Keith Olbermann
watch this space